it does make me a little bit sad as a
human just watching all the
breakthroughs on artificial intelligence
side when applied to Natural Sciences
now more and more to physics that the
creatures that will solve
the question of the origin of the nature
of life or just the process
the nature of life will be AI systems it
makes me a bit sad to I don't think so
uh because you think humans will at this
point in time remember who was behind AI
you know I I'm not buying in the
singularity thing yet
um
to AI is not aware AI is being built by
humans so
um AI is a tool an extremely smart tool
as long as we build it and as long as we
use it as a tool it remains a tool and I
think there is a lot of brouhaha and of
course science fiction and movies they
don't help see I got to push back a
little bit yes I agree with you for the
most part in terms of boo haha and
sci-fi
but there is like in the work of Deep
Mind we can look at chess so we can look
at protein folding
so chess is a simple one to First Look
at
what uh Alpha zero or which is their
game playing engine
was able to discover in our stockfish
about Chess humbles the best human
players not just is better than them
it comes up with ideas that the humans
don't understand and so the AI now is
telling you uh even though it's
programmed by humans the AI is saying
like
sacrificing a pawn here is a good idea
sacrificing a queen or a bishop here is
a good idea and then you start to kind
of Intuit as a human why but you don't
deeply understand and you can say that
AI is not conscious it doesn't deeply
understand the way humans do but there's
still a wisdom and a depth of knowledge
in that chess playing program that
humans don't have and the same with the
alpha fold with protein folding there's
a and now they're applying it to physics
to simulating nuclear reactions and so
on it feels like there might be a way to
understand the nature of life
that we can kind of Intuit poetically as
humans but the the true understanding
will come from a system that's much more
computationally sophisticated again you
know I would push back and my turn
because I still think that you men give
themselves ability
to do that by building that tool so the
idea that the tool you know we are
getting into the the carnitive scale and
and the Dark Forest and all these things
we can see the world this way uh at this
point in time for me
I still see
a grid tool
now uh whether the Sci-Fi scenario is
going to you know uh happen Etc I still
think that we are far away from from
this but if that tool is capable of
giving me A New Perspective uh it's just
that we are starting to jump into a
deeper uh cognition of of what the
universe is whether it's through our
brain or through a different way of
gathering information remember this is
what we do yeah human variables actually
build tools and then like integrate them
enter their way of thinking maybe
another generation has to be born that
is raised with those tools but we seem
to like
take for granted all the cool
Technologies you integrate into your way
of thinking a lot of people are growing
up now their mind is integrated with the
internet
you basically reconfigure the way you
memorize things you no longer have to
memorize a lot of facts because you can
look them up really quickly yeah and so
like uh so you uh reallocate a lot of
resources for uh thinking versus memory
of just strict facts that kind of stuff
when we integrate all of that yeah and
you know there I would completely agree
with you in fact I wrote about this
again uh um in this new book that's
coming out when is the book coming out
in January it's it will be in French
actually uh to start with you wrote it
in French actually I wrote it first in
English yes and I translated into French
so the the English version is already
pretty much ready to go uh if we found
the publisher in uh in the US but
anyways
um the point uh being here that I looked
at this as a relationship with
technology
as a complete change to me this is the
singularity more than anything else
which is the co-evolution of human with
technology not anymore with their
environment while we are messing up the
environment right now why we don't
respond to pandemic the way we should
because we are disconnected to the
environment we are taking our
information from and we were adapting
from right now exactly as you said we
take the information from the web from
the phones Etc we have no filter over
that information
before you were out in the environment
the information you get is the one the
planets is sending you now this
information is coming from different way
you have no way of knowing and
information is correct or not yeah I
gotta push back on that no you look at
this as a nickel system and it explains
a lot about Behavior see I like though
you said teenagers so we the technology
I think when we move past the teenager
stage enriches our ability to sense the
Earth to understand what's going on with
the environment it's just that we're
very so it's not that technology
disconnects us from the environment it
gives us more tools with which to
understand what's going on with the
environment that's true for the people
who are building the tools and know how
to use it take those tools now put them
in the general public with no filter
which is happening with social media
which is happening with a lot of things
and you see the disaster this is
creating and it's not the disaster it's
challenges you sound like a parent
talking about a teenager yes did you
it's it's The Growing Pains of a
civilization that is becoming deeply
connected
with our we can communicate all across
the world even through the pandemic the
good thing about technology this is also
something I wrote It's not the tools we
create that are bad it's the way we use
that yes and we're learning well this is
the cool thing and hopefully we'll do
all their learning before it's too late
because our response to what's going on
in the environment our response to
pandemics is deeply connected to this
disconnect we have with nature anyways
we all agree that we are in growing
pains and hopefully we can move forward
because there is a fantastic Universe
something absolutely magical around us
and I'm talking as a scientist I mean
there is Magic not in sense of you know
trickery but in sense of wonder around
us and there are so many signs where we
are getting so close
to Revolutions in cosmology in
astrobiology in astronomy which I think
to me this is where the hope lies and
also an Awakening of understanding that
we need to be in equilibrium with a
planet if we want to move forward
because even though we have these Big
Dreams of going on Mars and the moon and
listen I am a planetary geologist so I
am all for exploration right now the
moon or Mars is not going to save your
butt because for the logistics will
still depend very much on the earth and
for a long time I think this
time we are living in
will be remembered as a
pivot
in our history for for a number of
reasons uh a time where there is a
growing Consciousness where we are
creating tools that are going a little
bit ahead of us that we have some some
difficult time to catching up uh on with
where we have to deal with the
population that's way uh too big for the
planet we have we need to really learn a
sense of balance and and a maturity as a
civilization so how is this going to
unfold right now I have no clue I draw a
lot of optimism from the
similar things that happened
many decades ago when nuclear weapons
were developed
boy was that at the time even more
terrifying you just now created weapons
that could destroy the entirety of life
on Earth or not entirety but a lot of it
and we somehow found a balance
and they're the threat constantly is out
there and that threat has been made more
visceral in recent times
because the war in Ukraine
but we find a balance somehow so that I
have a threat of optimism for human
civilization that we that we figure it
out we're clever teenagers I think we
are clever teenagers there is definitely
a threat of optimism but I think it's
then
it's sin because something that has
changed as well
is the mentality of of humans
um although the threat was terrifying
when uh nuclear weapons were were
created
um there was a sense of
limits you were willing to push in the
threats
um there were there was a sense of
decency of moral values it was not
perfect but it was at least a time where
people could come together from very
different perspective and agree that
something was more important than
destroying everything but that's so
hilarious you say that yes you're
talking about a small Slither of humans
which is the scientists in the Manhattan
Project perhaps no that was also the
time when over a hundred million people
were tortured or murdered no no I agree
with that and Europe absolutely
absolutely I'm not talking about
scientists here actually I'm talking
about politicians we've gone beyond that
point now this is what I'm worried about
I mean
torture Etc unfortunately well we are
Apes exactly what you said so I think
that you know there is a lot to be not
not to blame Grandpa for that but
because we can always get better Grandpa
was a wild man
but we have to improve a lot on that
side before we can claim that we are a
mature civilization